i'm joined by dr jara dr jesus jara
clark county school district
superintendent dr jara thank you so much
for your time
now thank you for having me brian it's
always great to see you
it's good to see you look forward to an
in-studio in-person interview at some
point but for now we'll
we'll chat this way and if we could
start of course with the big issue of
schools
reopening and before we stay in the
present and look forward
if we could just take a look back and
the combination of the advice
of dr fauci of the cdc and the american
academy of pediatrics
uh that school should be open and should
be reopened and that the data
studying those private and parochial
catholic schools is in
and it's not showing the super spread of
schools that people worried about
back at the beginning of the pandemic
how do you address ccsd parents who say
why haven't our kids been in school yeah
you know what brian
one of the things that we've been
looking at is really um
how do we safely open our campuses and i
think
you know the plan we brought forward to
the board of trustees in january which
we brought in november
it was really the timing you know not
knowing and understanding a lot of the
the data from the beginning of the world
pandemic that we were facing
um it's really the um it was the perfect
timing when we came back in january we
felt that
at that point looking at all the
different facets of
of uh of what our kids were facing right
we you know we've had the health crisis
we've had the academic loss and some of
the other challenges that we face and
then looking at the mental health
of both our students and and our staff
we felt that was important to start
partnering and to come in
and find ways to look at a small
transition
in you know i i'll be honest i was a
little bit concerned
in november uh when you started seeing
the spiking of the cobit numbers going
up
up and looking at the the holiday season
then you see the spiking thanksgiving
spike of
of christmas then the decision was look
at a
look at a march timeline which is what
we announced to come in
face-to-face with the pre-k 3. i'm
really glad you pointed out the case
numbers because i i've heard
some of the pushback from people citing
case numbers in the general population
going up
but again the studies are showing that
that is just not happening the
major concern about uh student to
teacher and student to student
a transmission of covid now that the
data is in it's not happening at the
levels that they worried about in fact
some studies are showing uh students are
even safer in schools
as dr robert redfield talked about the
latest cdc
cdc study says that children would be
relatively safe returning back to the
classroom
with proper safety protocols in place
how does ccsd and you as the leader
address those safety protocols
you know what and so i apologize i was a
little late this uh this afternoon
that's that's exactly what we were doing
i was with the
state superintendent um the governor's
office the southern nevada health
district the state health officials
really making sure and really the the
partnership um and the support of the
governor
and his his executive team to really say
how do we
do we have everything in place and
that's what we were sharing going back
and we saw some gaps
and now there's going to be some
assistance from the state level and and
also from the county when i say the gap
just
do we have all our testing and part of
our agreement that we would have met
random selected cova testing for the
adults
in our campuses so putting all these
mitigating
um you know measures in place our
ventilation
cleaning our buildings and all these
different things um
are in place and i think uh we'll have
we have a great plan
that our parents will feel comfortable
with sending their kids to school
what about the issue which has clearly
broken your heart as it has
to report at the issue of suicidality
and the amount of mental
health challenges that have been
engendered due to the pandemic
uh you have spoken about this in one of
the recent articles
in the new york times you said regarding
kids they've got to start seeing some
movement they need some hope
which i think everyone can agree with
and when you think about those students
between the ages of nine up through high
school that have died by suicide
talk about the importance of addressing
the mental health
of students who have dealt with
something completely unprecedented
since march being essentially isolated
disconnected stuck on a screen
and talk about how we help those
children
yeah you know what uh brian um you know
it's been heartbreaking
um as a as a father and a superintendent
is really
how do we find ways for our children to
socialize you know obviously the
academics is so
important but where where our
hard-working educators
are interacting face to face uh
providing some of that social emotional
support
through through lessons it's a little
bit challenging when you're doing it
virtually
um and and those are some of the things
that we're bringing in you know
in making decisions to come back and
that was one of the pillars to
to speed up so kids can see that there's
light at the end of the tunnel
um that's going to be a long-term
uh approach here in clark county school
district because
once they start coming in we don't know
um
you know what they've been facing at
home and and then the economy the
parents
um so i think um when we start
looking at at the effects that we have
seen
um is something we need to really stay
focused on and we started
um a lifeline pilot with 12 schools now
we've grown it to 68 schools where
our social workers our school
psychologists are
really looking at the data um
the engagement in class the absenteeism
in school it's through distance that how
do we support them
and how do we start bringing them in we
started that and we're seeing some
really uh
positive um i would say interaction
in our school so we not only have to do
that now
do it when we come back but i think
long-term effects will
work as a community we have to continue
this
conversation to support our children and
you've given that light at the end of
the tunnel to the pre-k
through third graders are you concerned
at all that the
students have who have died by suicide
are between the age of fourth grade and
up through high school
which is the exact age range that will
continue to do school at home
essentially continuing that isolation
does that concern you
well you know what i've been concerned
all along right i mean this has been the
toughest
the toughest um you know um challenge
that i've had to face as an educator of
25 plus years
but one of the things that we added as
well i've been proud of the board's
decision on a unanimous vote for small
group
small group support so k-12
uh so four through 12 there's going to
be that
possibility for schools to identify
principles to identify with their teams
to start bringing in small groups for
academic support
for social emotional for extra tutorial
extra support so
you know that's where you start seeing
this positive
potential slow moving forward so there's
going to be some
opportunity for my educators and my you
know i have all the faith in the world
of our
our building principles to be able to
identify kids to bring them in for
some of the supports that we need to put
in place we talk about the different
aspects of life that are so important to
students the academic the social and of
course the sports
what do you think is going to happen
with sports we've heard about a one day
season or a one game season for
basketball we've heard about the
possibility of fall sports being played
like football in the spring and then
again a new season next fall
if the governor moves forward on
allowing sports to happen
what do you see as getting sports right
because these kids miss playing you know
that as their leader
no they i look i i do and
and as a former student athlete and as a
former
coach as well i get the critical
uh component that sports play in a kid's
life
but i also have to focus on the
instruction i have to focus on
the student part of the athlete the
student athlete and and when you start
thinking about
i need to bring in my high school
students my middle school students into
the classroom
first before you can look at the
extracurricular activities i know how
important it is
but if if we can't do the academics
then how can we focus on on on the
sports or even the performing arts which
are just as important
academics first then athletics and
performing arts and it is in terms of
the details still a work in progress
as to how exactly it'll be played out
they are and one of the things that i
want to make sure that you know because
there's folks out there saying well i've
canceled the fall sports
i haven't cancelled the fall sports for
august um
this is just you know if you recall the
seasons were all moved
so it's the current situation now so
august 21 22
you know the school year 21 22 there
hasn't been a decision around that
i want the kids to come back as soon as
possible
can we clarify vaccine availability to
ccsd staff
we had heard you know a week and a half
10 days ago at some educators saying hey
we're turned away a little bit of
misinformation
can you take a moment to clarify about
vaccine availability for ccsd educators
you know uh again part of the
conversation with the governor's office
in
in in the southern about health district
just this afternoon
uh you know right now we are
prioritizing pre-k three
um unlv and higher ed has stepped in
and and really provided a pod where our
folks can go in
the problem that we had you know that we
had when we were turning
folks away it wasn't that there wasn't
the availability it was just
the overrun really everybody just
getting excited to go get vaccinated
and now in coordination with the three
entities
our teachers our pre-k teachers support
staff
administrators bus drivers will look at
to start going into
the unlv pod to be a priority for us
fifth largest school district in the
country and while you're dealing with
the ramifications of a global pandemic
there's
other issues that ccsd still has to deal
with and
you've pointed out the teacher shortage
issue and the largest class size issue
how do you continue to address those
you know what uh we we've put together
um
you know back in eight months ago
really put together a commission to look
at our teacher retention
and recruitment strategies that we've
had
so the commission last week um actually
10 days ago delivered a report to me and
one of the things that we need to look
at
obviously recruitment is a priority but
then how do we do our hiring practices
how do we shrink
our our process to to make sure that
once we touch
and recruit them we get them in the
classroom as soon as possible so
a lot of great recommendations um but
i'm gonna tell you one of the big things
is we need to build our own we need to
build our own teachers within our
schools
working with higher ed get them through
and then bring them back in and recruit
them
we do have you know last year we had a
close to 12 000 students that
on first day were facing with with uh
you know a vacant position that's number
needs to shrink
because we need to address that to make
sure we get um
a highly qualified certified teacher in
every classroom
dr jerry you addressed this in in an
op-ed i read that you wrote
months ago and that is about when kids
fall behind
trying to get them caught up so in some
cases it's a real
uphill battle and i'm looking at the
fact that the percentage of f grades
given out doubled from
6 to 13 compared with fall of 2019
and of course these kids have been as we
talked about learning on a screen since
march we're going to talk about some of
the positives those teachers are doing
in that distance learning but first for
the amount of f's that have gone up
and kids that are falling behind without
that in-person
instruction how do we ever catch him up
it seems like a monumental task
it does and and one of the things that
you know we start with immediately
with our small groups right coming up
bringing them back in
and looking at some of the federal
dollars that are coming in
and what do we need to do is it a
year-round instruction
is it is it more support is it's not
going to be
what we call after school tutorial or
saturday school this is going to be a
long process
and i think the federal government we us
urban superintendents have been
you know raising the red flag um to our
our federal government to say this has
got to be an investment of the federal
government to really
accelerate the opportunities for our
kids um
so there's there's going to be the
immediate but then the long term has got
to be
a lot of different strategies that we
have already started the plan
to really be able to address a long term
for our schools
one of the things that i quote you again
here you said am i doing everything
possible to open our schools when you
look at the the recommendations from the
cdc american academy of pediatrics
even dr fauci talking about schools
should be
opened and should be reopened and yet
as those that are trying to reopen it
they deal with pushback they deal with
concerns some valid how do you continue
to move forward
when there are people that are concerned
it seems like you have to continue to
reference the studies that
that are in the data that is in how do
you deal with that pushback
well one of the things and i'm i'm gonna
tell you i'm very fortunate
i would say that we have a great
partnership with our teachers union
because we do have an agreement with our
teachers union to come back to school
face to face
not many districts do across the country
so proud of the work that we've done
here
um to really make sure that our teachers
felt safe
our our support professionals and all
our other employees
so so that's a huge step forward so
that's where you start saying
okay campuses are safe now let's address
the instructional model for our parents
to feel safe
to send their kids so that's where you
look at the partnerships and the
collaborations all unified the work is
hard enough
pre-coping um so bringing everybody in
um to say are we all on the common
mission to bring in our goods
our children to school and that's one of
the things that
we i feel honored and to work with my
colleagues across the table
to really be able to bring it bring a
plan that supports our kids and i'm
excited about that
a lot of moving parts and that
excitement is genuine because we know
uh i kids are so excited to see their
friends again and to be around their
teachers and
to have that and boy it's needed for
them after that long stretch away
but i want to address the positive of
the men and women who were
teaching under very difficult
circumstances of distance learning
we did some cool at schools kind of a
home edition if you will it featured
some of those stories
talk about how impressed you've been
with
what these teachers have done to step up
in really very difficult circumstances
oh absolutely i i am so
proud of the 42 000 employees i mean you
talk about the fifth largest district
turned upside down
and jumped in right and do distance
education and you know from food service
department to going in 9 million meals
in this community bus drivers to look at
support professionals to be able to jump
in our staff
um and our teachers right i mean i i had
an opportunity to substitute in the
classroom
it's hard you know because i'm going to
tell you you got 18 and
you got some you know 18 17
kids in there they're all chatting away
different times and coming in and then
you're
looking into you're not seeing their
face you're seeing phone numbers
it's hard and kudos to our teachers
you know and then some creative lessons
that i've seen videos i've seen teachers
outside trying to get our kids engaged
i am so proud of our educators
during these difficult times that i did
you know
say we're in and we're going to do the
best we can and and i couldn't be more
proud of all the work that they've done
those last nine months
lastly dr jarrah's student truancy with
online learning
the kids that aren't jumping on the zoom
that that are hard to reach
maybe clicking on and clicking off how
is that still being addressed because
the fourth graders and older will
continue at home for at least the
interim
yeah you know what we're doing wellness
checks our truenc officers have gone in
and really and home home visits you know
this is where our teachers
our educators are so passionate about
our kids
and those are all the things that
they're going and checking in at home
whether it's a principal
a truancy officer do do wellness checks
are you checking in
why not what's going on how can we help
you partnership with the county and
looking at the harbor any other social
wraparound services that we need to
provide our kids those are all the
things that we're doing
um to help them and i'm gonna you know
just really i thanked all my teachers
42 000 employees and i want to thank you
our parents you're right we
you guys have become our adjunct
teachers um
to really chime in and really help our
kids which has been phenomenal
um so you know great community great
support
it hasn't been easy it's been difficult
it's not perfect
but given the circumstances i'm proud of
the work that's taking place in this
community on behalf of our kids
dr jarrow we really appreciate your time
and covering some really tough topics in
what is
an unprecedented time and we look
forward to uh continuing to see the
improvement and getting those kids back
in the classroom we thank you for your
hard work
and your time thank you so much brian
love to see you soon
all right me as well thanks dr jar take
care
bye now